hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and you know yesterday i got an email
and the question was basically you know
is it possible to trade the evening
session order flow and you know i
started writing a reply and it was just
such a long reply i thought you know
what hey it might be a little bit easier
for me just to shoot this quick video
and and throw it up on youtube because
i'm sure a lot of other people are kind
of curious about you know basically the
same question
so you know is it possible to trade the
evening session yes it is okay and you
know let me just pull up a chart here
okay
this is a footprint chart of
crude oil on a one minute basis um last
night you know about eight o'clock now
in when i when i say the evening session
there's actually you know the market
reopens at 5 p.m chicago time
and then it trades the next day to 4 p.m
so there's basically three sessions
right there's
um the asian session the european
session the us session right we all know
that um
us session you know really kicks off
about 7 a.m chicago time um european
session kicks off
around 1 a.m chicago time you know those
markets in europe start opening up the
futures markets at 1am asian session
even though the market reopens at 5 00
pm asia doesn't really kick off until
around 8 00 pm chicago time because um
you know depending on on you know if
we're on daylight savings time or not
you know 5 p.m
is really more the australian session um
you know the cash markets in asia you
know tokyo
market doesn't open until eight uh 8 a.m
um tokyo time
in in hong kong is is like 10 a.m
actually 10 you know 10 a.m hong kong
time so you know it's it's they don't
open at the 5 p.m or you know 6 p.m time
in chicago they open a little bit later
but that again is not to say that you
can't trade during that 5 pm until 8 pm
time i mean you can but you know granted
volumes there is going to be a little
bit lighter now one of the drawbacks for
trading during the asian hours is when
the market is slow
it's very slow it could be like staring
at the wall watching the paint dry okay
it's going to take longer for moves to
manifest
now of course there are going to be
times where there are very quick moves i
mean you know i i
you know i don't want to say you know i
miss donald trump but you know when when
trump was president you know you could
just be sitting there twiddling your
thumbs the next thing you know the
market you jump five points in the
e-minis because you know trump tweeted
something or you know some you know he
was at a dinner and he said something it
got reported
you don't really have that
this year under this new administration
but again that that doesn't mean that
quick moves don't happen now
the volumes in major contracts are good
enough during the asian hours to make
trading decisions based on the order
flow now major markets you know i'm
referring to you know e-mini
crude oil to lesser extent gold you know
some of the smaller markets like the
grain markets and you know ultra bonds
bonds you might want to steer clear of
those until you really start to
understand order flow a bit more it's
just because the volume there is is is
lighter right there's just not much
activity as compared to the day session
but if you stick with the major markets
uh you should be fine right so
most people the mistake though that i
see that traders make is when they're
trying to trade during the evening
session
they're using the same type of chart
that they would use during the day
session when there's a lot more volume
okay so this is a crude oil one minute
chart right the footprint chart and if
you're looking here this is 8 p.m here
let me get the crosshairs up here
uh where are we here so 8 p.m here the
market started sliding okay now
if you're just looking at it it doesn't
really give you much really one way or
the other i mean there's some things
here you know the point of control here
point control here
um but it's just more or less going
sideways it's basically trading in this
range between 50 and 34
okay and just sort of going there
and if you're looking at the deltas
it it's small right and when you start
looking at small delta in a market
that's going sideways
it's really enough to sort of put you to
sleep because it's like gosh you know
you're trying to sell the
you know break down here it only goes
three ticks in your favor then oh you
try to buy you know some support here
you know it goes three ticks in your
favor and basically most of the time
it's just spinning around it's hard to
get any real grasp of of what's going on
especially you know looking at points of
controls they're all over the place
you know you know some are go you know
it's starts here higher higher higher
than lower lower higher lower lower
lower it starts to migrate down here
towards the end
um but more or less it's just sort of
stuck in this band here you know trading
between 34 and you know i want to say 50
but you know realistically
you know 44
okay and again deltas are small 7 1 14
27 32 4
34.
now
what i suggest is
instead of looking at the same type of
chart that you're so comfortable with
during the day session
you want to sort of combine the volume a
bit more so the easy way to do it is
look at a five minute chart instead of a
one minute chart okay so this is a five
minute chart in crude oil
okay same time eight o'clock right 805 8
10 8 15 8 20
etc okay but now you're starting to see
sort of you know better chunking or
clumps of data that you can get your
wrap your head around right you can see
here right this is a divergence here
right you got this is a new high last
night 84 51
and the market starts moving down right
you got delta increasing minus 7 minus
45 minus 135 is actually a delta search
okay you see points of control migrating
lower
okay what else you see in here um you
know some signs in the max and min delta
as well that's bearish so you know it's
just a little bit easier
to wrap your head around when you have
more volume to analyze
than trying to analyze it you know sort
of on a micro sense when it's not really
much going on
okay so
another way that i recommend for traders
is to use
um you know some order flow tools now
you know i have tools that analyze delta
that analyze points of control and you
know for the evening session
a great tool for using is the delta
scalper
all right now the delta scalper
will give you buy and sell signals based
on the delta right this is the
five-minute chart here on what's
happening in the delta how market is
moving you know swing highs swing lows
so while a market you know like this
market is just basically going sideways
in here right i don't want to say it's
rallying here i mean i guess you could
say it's rallied from you know 25 up to
45 a 20 cent rally okay
you know then it sold off from
obviously from you know the 30 area here
you know down to you know 8 400
um you know popped back up again and
then it sold off some more right down
um you know overnight but
if you had tools that are going to help
you analyze the order flow and the delta
scalper is one of them right you can see
here it caught this move
right over here
right this is that five minute period
here right the five minute bar is eight
o'clock eight oh five eight ten right
it's giving you that sell signal right
there what you're seeing
happening in here
is giving you that sell signal
right and earlier right it had a little
buy here okay you know 8440 up to 50 not
the biggest move
again this is sort of that
five o'clock until eight o'clock time
period
you know market's going to move but
probably not very much
you know really what you want to be
concentrating on if you are trading the
evening session wait till 8 o'clock
that's when more volume is going to come
in you know asia people don't realize
this but asia is a big oil trading
center especially if you're trading
crude oil
you know really where you want to be
focusing on is starting at at eight
o'clock
um you know people say well you know
what mike that's just you know one chart
on one day well let's take a look at the
previous day um
okay so you know eight o'clock here it's
got a nice little move here down from
this you know the 70s areas down to the
50s and then back up here you know this
is where the buy signal is from 80s back
above 8 400
okay
you know obviously it gave it all back
but
you know you could catch 20 ticks here
20 ticks there you know you're not
looking for the 100 point move
in the asian session right you're
looking for
consistent moves that are happening you
know
almost daily
this is the the day before the 25th
right this is seven o'clock go here
eight o'clock 7 55 8 o'clock
triggers this is the bar with this
um this is the bar with the uh
conditions met 7 50
p.m
you know it's giving you the buy signal
right here right you know as asia is
opening
for a nice move up you know hopefully
you could have caught that
then on the way back down you know this
is where your stop's going to be above
75 76
um you know you're getting short in here
worst case scenario 62. it does rally
back up about 10 ticks 12 ticks
you know before selling off going into
the european session
okay you know i might make another video
talking about the european session
because you know the european session
there are good moves that happen there
as well and you can see this move right
here this nice strong move up
during the european session from 50
all the way up
to above 85 bucks
that was sunday night you know take a
look at um
monday again the european session
starts taking off you know 83 45
all the way up to you know basically 84
bucks or you get that sell signal and
you get another sell signal up here
84 15 that's the u.s hours
um
and today today is uh the 27th
european session what what happened
right you got a sell signal here right
on on the european
open
you know from 70-ish 72-ish you know
down into the 50s
um this bicycle didn't work out then you
got another cell signal again from the
50s you know all the way down to the 20s
this buy signal didn't work out but you
know nevertheless you know i want you to
see these these moves that you know are
possible right day session nice move up
here so this is the
the delta scalper and again it takes all
this information that you're seeing here
in the delta all right and again you
know that's a this is a five minute
chart you can see here
if you're looking at a one minute chart
during these times where periods of
illiquidity
well not say illiquidity i mean there's
trading going on but not a whole lot
switch it up switch to a five minute
chart right so that the data becomes
easier to read because you're you're
basically taking
you know it's a five-minute part you're
taking you know the five-minute period
and put it in it
taking that volume and combining it yeah
because seven one fourteen twenty-seven
you know
that's if you're looking at one minute
chart that time period there's not much
information to go off of right that's
going to give you much um to trade in
terms of delta but when you combine it
all together
okay yeah you know what this
now you can start to see this delta is
making more sense right it's clearer 745
135 right you've seen the increase in
delta um you see the max delta
decreasing
the min delta
increasing you know as the market's
getting ready to sell off
so
hopefully you found this
video useful
and again you know
sometimes you have to switch it up
during times where there's just not a
whole lot going on in terms of volume
right order flow is about reading the
volume
and if if you're trying to read volume
that just isn't there
it
it's going to be difficult right so why
make it harder on yourself trying to
understand oh god you know seven you
know minus one what does that mean
you know nothing doesn't mean anything
right seven minus one is basically
neutral you know if there was an
extra one second this bar could have had
a positive delta of one right could have
had a positive delta of three
but when you put it into a five minute
period it just makes
understanding it a bit more easier so
again you know enjoy the video and i'll
put some more up explaining different
types of things for you bye bye